i know that many of you would love to
become more productive and this
certainly applies to me as well but how
can you accomplish that one person from
the audience a couple of weeks ago sent
me a list from a service called filtered
where they analyzed what 100
productivity hacks and made a ranking
out of it so welcome to a new coffee
break here on my channel in this video i
will look into the top 10 productivity
hacks and i will give you my view
whether these are really effective or
not in the past i was sometimes a bit
skeptical about these productivity tips
i made a video about this in the past as
well linking it somewhere above here but
in the end of this video i will also
share one bonus tip a productivity tip
that really helped me in my life so stay
tuned and get into it the first
productivity tip i want to talk about is
time boxing time boxing means that you
look at your calendar you plan your week
or your month ahead and you schedule
some time into your calendar for things
that you really would like to accomplish
and i feel like this is especially
effective for things that are outside of
your regular work of course in your
regular work you know that you will need
to make the time for the things that
really matter but what is everything
that comes on top of that maybe you have
some side projects that you want to work
on maybe you have an exercise routine
that you want to prioritize make sure
that you block off this time in the
calendar and then be realistic we'll
even have enough time in the evenings on
the weekends to get this done make sure
to prioritize accordingly to get this
right next step is prioritization it is
of course essential that at work you
prioritize your tasks in the right way
so let me share three tips here these
are the rule of thumbs that i think
apply most of the time first focus on
things that need to move to other
people's desks so if someone else is
waiting for an input from you then this
person is able to progress the work by
him or herself prioritize this make sure
you get this through this other person's
desk as quickly as possible because then
you can also expect to get the result
back rather quickly of significantly
increasing productivity of the whole
team next do things first that usually
lead to some quick wins to some quick
results it's often quite frustrating if
you receive a project a task maybe from
your leadership and you do some things
first where you know that only in one or
two or three days of work you can
actually have something presentable in
your hand and of course then if your
leadership reaches out to you after one
day ask what you have done and you don't
really have anything you can show for
that's awful another idea and third to
prevent burnout especially when you're
sitting at your desk in the evening it's
already getting late
always ask yourself this specific piece
of work where you now feel like you need
to work on it right now
do you really need it for tomorrow is it
needed for your work day tomorrow and if
it's not do not work on it in the
evening next is the skill of saying no
especially juniors often feel like they
need to do everything that someone asked
them to do this is of course not really
a sustainable way of looking at your
work and if you struggle with this if
you struggle with saying no in such a
work environment i created a video in
the past where i also shared specific
tips on this situation i will link it
above fear feel free to check it out
next productivity tip is to move during
the day if you just sit in front of a
big screen from early morning until late
evening you will very likely get
depressed at some point your energy
level just naturally will go down what i
implemented for myself is now since a
couple of weeks almost every day from
monday to friday during lunch break i go
to the gym i signed up for a gym very
close to my office and then after i just
pick up something quick to eat during a
video conference or something like that
so that i do get some food in as well i
know this is not possible in every
single job but even at mckinsey during
my time in consulting i was able to at
least go for short walk maybe outside of
your clients building outside of your
home this does make a big difference
just to get some fresh air because
otherwise there might be days where you
don't even see the sun if in the early
morning you go into the office and then
off once you come back from the office
the sun has already gone down that's of
course not really a great environment to
work in next step control your devices
we all have experienced the situation
you receive a new email and then you
open slack and you see 500 messages on
slack that you look at your phone lots
of notifications on your phone how can
you even concentrate on this environment
how can you even get anything done in
this situation try to schedule some time
in your calendar maybe with time boxing
where you focus on working on your
emails to make sure that you really have
some time of uninterrupted work where
you can do some deep work done without
getting interrupted all the time by
these types of things if so far you took
any value out of this video please
destroy the like button and subscribe
for the youtube algorithm this would be
much appreciated and of course if you
have additional tips on productivity to
share leave me a comment in the comment
section but now let's continue next
productivity tip is to take short breaks
this is of course very much related to
the tip to move but of course if you are
the personality that just sits at his or
her desk and you really struggle to do
something else think about other tasks
incorporate a couple of these short
breaks frankly in an office environment
often this would be just a quick chat
with a colleague a little coffee break
in my humble opinion most people in
these environments don't really lack
these types of breaks but if you do make
sure to have the time for me again a big
game changer was the exercise the gym
time during the day that in itself is of
course a valuable breakaway next
productivity hack is to have an actively
managed to-do list either on a written
sheet or just in one of the many to-do
management apps that you can get on your
mobile phone on the pc on mac and so on
the main reason why this makes sense is
because it gives you peace of mind if
you don't write down all your to-do's
first it's very likely that you will
forget something and second you will
always feel stressed because suddenly
some to-do's pop up in your mind and you
don't really know whether this is
something to do now or maybe later you
are just afraid of forgetting it so
whenever you get a new task that you
need to get done just dump it in any of
these to do management programs because
then you know for sure that you will
have them all written down that you
won't forget anything and besides that
maybe that's also personality thing but
i feel like there's very few things
which are as satisfying as having a
sheet of paper in front of you or even
also one of these apps and being able to
just cross off to do's from that list
that personally always gives me a little
sense of accomplishment during the day a
little sense of self-efficacy so if you
feel in a similar way about that try it
out next productivity tip is to eat well
trust you all had the experience of
having had a very heavy lunch and then
in the afternoon just feeling down just
feeling like you lack any energy to get
anything productive done for the next
one two or even three hours that's of
course not great and probably also not
really healthy so avoid heavy lunches
and also be careful about all the snacks
that you eat during the day in some
companies in almost all meeting rooms
there are baskets of sweets of chocolate
and so on and it's just so easy to in
every other meeting eating a bit of this
chocolate so try to replace these snacks
with more healthy alternatives next
productivity tip is the two minute rule
this rule says that whenever you can get
a task done in two minutes do it now
don't postpone it to later if something
can get done in two minutes there's
really no reason to not taking action
right now don't even bother tracking it
in your to-do app just the fact that you
open your app or take your piece of
paper with your to-do's and you write it
down this alone will take one minute or
so right so just get it done right now
then it's finished and you're fine next
tip is to control your social media
consumption this is a problem that many
people have me included that you just
waste far too much time on all these
apps instagram facebook tech talk and so
on i think in most professional context
it's actually linkedin linkedin now
became this big social network where you
can read all these posts watch all these
videos and the mean thing is that for
many jobs you actually need linkedin as
one of the tools that you need for your
job frankly due to this reason i haven't
even found a good way of organizing
myself in this regard so if you have any
good tips to share on that just leave a
comment in the comment section
now finally i want to share the one
bonus advice that was not even present
in this list that i initially talked
about but i feel had a quite significant
impact on my life so many people are
using actually big headphones noise
cancelling headphones
in your work routine to just blend out
the noise and so on but in my humble
experience there is something that is
far more effective than all these noise
cancelling headphones and this is proper
earplug something like i have here in my
hand i start using these in university
especially during exams so it was always
allowed during exams to plug in ear
plugs like this and i feel like just the
fact alone that i used earplugs during
most of my exams helped me to improve my
grades by at least one or two points on
all of these exams at least for me
personally this was such a game changer
in how well i was able to concentrate
and even today whenever i want to have
focused quality work time of one hour
two hours or so we just want to sit in
front of my desk to get something done
there's nothing else that helps me as
much to concentrate as proper earplugs
again if you found this helpful please
leave a like i would very much
appreciate that big big thanks to all
the members of the channel for
supporting the work here at firm
learning my name is heinrich i release
weekly videos here on the channel see
you again next week until then and bye